Kuwait is, along with Qatar, the only country
in the Arabian Peninsula where elections are
held. Yep, you heard that right...
Many of you might know this country because
of their oil reserves, their wealth, or the
fact that they were invaded by SADDAM HUSSEIN
in the 90s. But Kuwait is much more than that.
It is one of the most tolerant nations in
the Islamic world. Women can vote, run for
office, and they even have a female MP. But
not only that, for decades, the Kuwaiti
Royal House has been America’s best friend
in the Gulf. This is why, when they were invaded
in 1990, Uncle Sam didn’t hesitate for a
moment, and sent their troops in immediately.
And now you might wonder: why are we talking
today about Kuwait? Well, this is the only
Arab country, alongside with Oman, that hasn’t
joined the diplomatic block of Qatar.
Saudi Arabia, Bahrain, Egypt and the United
Arab Emiratesbroke off relations with Qatarin
the worst diplomatic crisis to hit Gulf Arab
states in decades. The three Gulf countries
and Egypt accused Qatar of supporting terrorism
and destabilizing the region.]
And now the question is why is Kuwait not
on this list of nations who have cut ties
with Qatar? What kind of interest does this
country have in this diplomatic crisis? How
does their political system work? Well, today,
we are going to answer these questions. But
before we do, let’s get to know more about
this particular part of the planet.
WHO IS WHO IN THE PERSIAN GULF?
The first country we need to know about in
the Arabian Peninsula is Saudi Arabia. Saudi
Arabia is the biggest country in the region,
both in terms of population and territory.
But it is not the only one... Here we have
the United Arab Emirates, which Dubai and
Abu Dhabi are part of. This country has its
own government, its own laws, and its own
currency. Is absolutely independent from the
Saudis.
The same goes for Qatar, which has its own
foreign policy and holds better relations
with public enemies of the Saudis like the
Islamic Republic of IRAN. And now you might
be thinking that all of this countries have
one important thing in common... the fact
that they are incredibly oil-rich, right?
Well… actually that’s pretty wrong. Here
we have the Republic of Yemen: a country that
is extremely poor. Now, of course, all of
this countries have a common history, traditions
and religion. But make no mistake, each of
them have their own peculiarities.
For example, the United Arab Emirates was
the first country who realized oil is not
forever and therefore, they decided to diversify
their economy. Today, crude represents just
3% of the total economy of Dubai.
Kuwait is also a totally different animal.
Yes, they have a monarchy, the so-called EMIR,
but he is controlled by a constitution and
a parliament. But hold on just a second, because
this doesn't mean they are a 100% democratic
country. In fact, their system is way more
complicated than that. So, let’s have a
look at it.
HOW DOES SEMI-DEMOCRACY WORK IN KUWAIT?
So, Kuwait is known as a “semi-democracy.”
Unlike Saudi Arabia, Kuwait has freedom of
religion. This is why you can find even a
Catholic church in the middle of Kuwait city.
Things like the HIJAB are not mandatory, and
even the laws regarding alcohol are fairly
liberal in comparison with it’s neighbours.
Of course, it’s still forbidden to buy it
or sell it. But it’s legal to drink in private.
Nonetheless, the main peculiarity about Kuwait
are their elections. All the adult, natural-born
citizens have the right to vote for their
parliament every four years. This includes
women. In this elections, political parties
are forbidden. But this doesn't mean candidates
have no ideology at all. They can also campaign
freely and have debates.
Needless to say, the political debate here
is totally different compared to that in the
UK or US, for example. Here, the political
spectrum is not only a right-wing / left-wing
kind of thing. Of course, some candidates
are highly conservative and others are more
liberal and open to Western culture, but this
not the only thing that divides the Kuwaiti
society.
There is also a never-ending fight between
Sunni muslims and Shia ones. This is because,
as I said before, there is freedom of religion,
and that means the creed of the candidate
is as important as his tax plan. But not only
that, there is another big divide between
the so-called urban voters and the tribal
ones. Just think about it, this is a country
with a long nomadic tradition, with half of
the population still living in tribes. And
these tribes hold their own primaries to choose
their candidates.
This said, elections are used to choose a
national assembly with the power to make laws
and even put a veto on the policies taken
by the executive branch.
And now you might be wondering… How do they
choose their Prime Minister? Are they voted
for by the MPs as they do in European countries?
Or do they hold presidential elections like
they do in USA? Well, it’s actually nothing
like either of those… As I said, Kuwait
is a semi-democracy. This means the Head of
the State is the EMIR and he chooses the prime
minister and his cabinet.
Does it sound sort of like those European
absolute monarchies that you studied at the
history lessons? Well, it’s not exactly
like that... In fact, in Arab Monarchies,
the position of the Emir is not inherited.
This is why in Saudi Arabia they have big
internal battles to choose their leaders.
And, as I explained in a previous video, Royal
Families in this part of the planet can have
thousands of members.
So in the case of Kuwait, the members of their
Royal family, the so-called, AL-SABAH house
can vote for the Emir. But right after, the
national assembly has to vote on whether they
accept this decision or not.
But wait just a minute because just incase
the system were not complicated enough, here
is another extra fact: the Constitution allows
the Emir to dissolve the parliament anytime
he wants. And, well, that’s something he
does pretty often…
Emir of Kuwait dissolves parliament
The move, announced on state media after an
emergency government meeting, sets the stage
for early elections.
And, believe me, parliamentary debates in
Kuwait are far from being quiet. Emergency
meetings are a common thing and sometimes
its really hard to get to any kind of consensus.
For some analysts, this is one of the reasons
that explains this...
A CRUDE-A-HOLIC ECONOMY
We all know it: oil-rich countries have so
much money they can spend it as if there was
no tomorrow. Most natural-born Kuwaiti citizens
work as civil servants for the government.
They pay no income tax, their energy bills
are subsidized, and their salaries are ludicrously
high.
The ones who work on the oil rigs are the
foreigners. But this is not only a reality
for Kuwait. It happens all over the region.
Black gold has allowed all of these countries
to have this way of life.
But what happens now? As you know, the market
price for crude oil has fallen in recent years.
Of course, these oil-monarchies are still
making profits, but not enough to keep that
system going. And this is why today, all of
these countries have fiscal deficits. This
means their spending is way higher than their
income.
Pay attention to the chart here! Even in USA,
where they are really worried about their
high deficit, is doing better than this countries.
And now you might wonder... What does this
figure actually mean? Well… this means that
if the Kuwaitis don’t want to go bankrupt
in a few years, they’d better find other
alternative incomes and not rely entirely
on oil.
Nonetheless, despite Kuwait having the most
modern and democratic political system, they
have the highest dependence on crude oil.
Even Saudi Arabia, regressive as they are,
is better prepared for a price in the price
of oil. And this is a surprise for everybody
because, during the 1970s, Kuwait was the
rock star of the region. Now, this title goes
to Dubai, despite it being an absolute monarchy.
And this has left many Arabs wondering whether
democracy is compatible with economic reform.
Kuwait has stagnated, frustrating the people
of a country once seen as a Middle East trailblazer.
Let’s say you want to start a logistics
company in Dubai. You just need to buy some
land and build the facilities, right? Well,
in Kuwait, this is almost impossible. The
government owns 90% of the territory. On the
other hand, bureaucracy has reached insane
levels. According to the World Bank, it´s
easier to start a business in countries like
Ukraine or El Salvador than it is in Kuwait.
And all of this, despite the fact that Kuwait
has a lower corporate tax than Luxembourg.
Added to this are the sky-high salaries of
civil workers, which rise year after year,
and you can probably imagine that no one is
going to become an entrepreneur and leave
behind the comfort and the safety of a government
job.
But now, all of a sudden, the Qatari crisis
has offered Kuwait a chance to emerge as a
regional leader. Their royal house has good
relationships with all the countries involved:
including United States, Saudi Arabia and
Qatar. Plus, their political system is the
most open and democratic in the region. In
other words, they have the best chance of
becoming a mediator in this crisis. And they
are well aware of it.
Kuwaiti Emir to travel to Saudi for Qatar
talks
So now the question is… Do you think Kuwait
can take back its role as a regional leader?
Can this crisis help them to showcase their
country for foreign investment? Let us know
what you think in the comments below.
Meanwhile, things are far from quiet in Saudi
Arabia. Their Royal House is having an internal
war to determine who is going be the successor
of the Prince. Click here to know more about
this story.
And of course, don't forget to visit our friends
from the RECONSIDER MEDIA podcast. They provided
the voice heard on this video that isn’t
mine.
And don't forget that we publish brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday. So
subscribe to the channel and you will not
miss any videos!
Finally, if you like this video, give us a
THUMBS UP and, as always… I’ll see you
in the next video!